we have an infinite series here and the
first thing i'd like you to try is to
pause this video and see if you can
express this as an infinite geometric
series and if you can express it as an
infinite geometric series see what its
sum would be given an interval of
convergence so figure out what over what
interval of x is would your infinite
geometric series converge and what would
that sum actually be
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's try to work through this
together so the first thing i want to do
is let me just factor out a common
factor this might simplify it in terms
of trying to express it so let's see if
i factor out looks like all of these are
divisible by 3x squared so i can rewrite
this as 3
x squared times
minus
x to the third power
plus x to the sixth power
minus x to the
minus x to the ninth power and a pattern
is starting to emerge
and let me actually close the brackets
with the same color with that pink right
over there
and let's see this looks like we are
taking powers of x to the third so let
me write it that way this is the same
thing as 3x squared
times
we could write this first term or i
could say i could say the zeroth term
this is x to the third
to the zeroth power then minus this is x
to the third
to the first power and then plus this is
x to the third
to the second power and then i think you
see what's going on this is x to the
third to the third power and of course
we can keep going but now we have to
worry about this the switching of signs
that we keep having so this would be
negative one this is positive which is
the same thing as negative one to the
zero power this is negative which is
negative one to the first power so let's
actually write it this way we can write
it as three
x squared
times
this first term we could write it as
negative 1 or we could just write as
negative x to the third
to the 0th power
and then you're going to say plus or
plus we could say negative x to the
third to the first power negative one to
the first power is negative one negative
x to the third to the first power is x
to the third
plus
negative x to the third to the second
power
plus
negative x to the third to the third
power that's this term right over here
negative one to the third power is
negative one and of course x to the
third to the third is x to the ninth and
it keeps going and so this makes it a
lot clearer what our common ratio is our
common ratio here is
is negative x to the third and over what
interval would this converge well it's
going to converge if our comment if the
absolute value of our common ratio
is less than one
so we're going to converge
converge
if
the absolute value of our common ratio
which is negative
x to the third is less than one or
another way of saying this is the same
thing the absolute value of a negative
is going to be the same thing as the
absolute value of a positive so that's
the same way as saying the absolute
value of x to the third
is less than one or saying that x to the
third is less than one and is greater
than
negative one and the way that's going to
happen if you take if you take the cube
roots of both sides of this of or all
the sides of this inequality you're
going to get that x is going to be
between
negative 1 and 1. this right over here
is our interval of convergence
interval
of convergence
and if we restrict our x's to that what
is this going to sum to was infinite
geometric series our common ratio its
absolute value is less than one
and so this is going to sum to
this is going to be equal to our first
term i guess we could say or the thing
that's multiplying by this whole thing
but if you multiply it out this would be
our first term
is going to be 3x squared
all of that over
minus our common ratio so 1 minus
negative x to the third well that's just
going to be 1 plus
x to the third
so everything we've done so far
is we've shown
we've shown that this let me actually
write it this way that this thing
is equal to this thing over the interval
of convergence
so let me write the copy
and paste it so right like that over the
interval of convergence if x is between
negative one and one these two things
are the same
now we can start to put our calculus hat
on here because this looks interesting
this you might remember this looks like
the derivative of something that's
familiar 1 plus x to the third what's
the derivative of that well that's 3x
squared
so
it looks like this is the this right
over here is the derivative of the
natural log of 1 plus x to the third or
the absolute value of 1 plus x to the
third and if you don't believe me let's
take the anti-derivative of this thing
right over here in fact for fun let's
take the anti-derivative of both sides
of this and if we do that then we'll we
will have shown essentially a a a
geometric series representation of
whatever the antiderivative of this
thing is so i encourage you to pause the
video again and try to take the
antiderivative of both sides of this
equation
so let's take so we're going to take the
anti-derivative of the left-hand side
and we're going to take the
anti-derivative
the anti-derivative of the right-hand
side
now on the left-hand side i mentioned
that hey it looks like we have a
expression and its derivative that just
calls out for u substitution so if we
say that u
is equal to 1 plus x to the third
let me write this down so
u is equal to 1 plus x to the third then
what's d u going to be so then du
is going to be equal to 3
x squared
dx so notice we have u
and then d u
d u
is this right over here
so this this expression right over here
could be rewritten as
let me go over here this could be
rewritten as the integral the integral
of
d u
over u
over u or i could say one actually let
me write it as one over u d u
one over u
d u
which of course is equal to
which is going to be equal to the
natural log
of the absolute value of u
the natural log of the absolute value of
u
plus
plus some constant
plus sub-constant and we of course know
that u is one plus x to the third so
this is going to be equal to
the natural log of the absolute value of
one plus x to the third
one plus x to the third plus c
plus c
now we're restricting our domain for x
being between negative one and one so
for that domain this thing is always
going to be
this thing is always going to be
non the salting actually is always going
to be positive so let's so what we can
do we can
we don't have to write the absolute
value sign so this is going to be equal
to the natural log
let me write it
the natural log of 1 plus x to the third
one plus x to the third plus c
plus c so that's this left hand side and
the right hand side's actually a lot
more straightforward this is just a
straightforward polynomial now as you
can imagine we're going to get a plus
some type of constant there so let me
differentiate them a little bit let me
call this one c1 and then on the right
hand side
what do we get the antiderivative
of this
is going to be let's see the
antiderivative of x squared is x to the
third divided by three
so this first term the antiderivative is
just going to be x to the third power
the derivative of x to the third is
three x squared now this term right over
here
negative 3x to the fifth the
antiderivative of of x to the fifth is x
to the sixth
x to the sixth
over
six
x to the sixth over six but then we have
that three over here three over six is
2. so it's negative
x
to the sixth
over 2.
let me do that in a different color just
so we can keep track of it
so this one right over here is negative
the antiderivative is negative x to the
sixth
over two
and then let's see i'm running out of
colors the anti-derivative of x to the
eighth is x to the ninth over nine so
it's going to be plus x to the ninth
and then we have this three three over
nine is three
and i think you see a pattern happening
and then let's just do one more of these
for fun x to the 12th over 12 but we
have this 3 so negative x to the 12th
over
4 and then we keep going and then we're
of course going to have we're going to
have some constant and actually let me
put the constant in the front
so let me copy and paste that
or cut and paste that
so i have some space
so let me
let me
right over here i'll put some other
constant c2 it doesn't have to be the
same one
plus all of this
now to simplify this i could subtract c1
from both sides or essentially from c2
and then i'm going to have
i'm going to have the natural log
of
1 plus x to the third power 1 plus x to
the third power this is kind of neat
what we've just done with a little bit
of integration
is equal to
c2 minus c1 well this is some constant
minus some other constant so that's just
going to be some arbitrary constant
some arbitrary constant plus all of this
business
plus all of this business and we can
even figure out what the constant is
going to be by trying out some values of
x that's in our that that's in our
restricted domain
well x equals 0 is between negative 1
and 1. so let's see what happens
when x is equal to 0 to solve for c
if x is equal to 0
if x is equal to 0 we get natural log
natural log of
is equal to
c
c plus well all of these terms are going
to be zero zero to the third power minus
zero to six on and on and on plus zero
plus zero
or another way and natural log of one of
course e to the what power is one well
that's zero
so c must be 0. c is equal to 0. so this
thing right over here is equal to 0. so
what we've just done using a little bit
of integration
is starting with a
let's just appreciate what went on
starting with a an arbitrary infinite
series we showed it could be represented
as a geometric series we defined an
interval of convergence over which this
would converge over which the common
ratio's absolute value is less than one
and then using that we we expressed its
sum and then we took the anti-derivative
of both sides to figure out
to figure out an expansion
for the natural log of one plus
one plus x to the third power which so
so at least in my mind that was pretty
neat this is what we
natural log of one plus x to the third
power is x to the third power minus x to
the sixth over two plus x to the ninth
over three
so on and on and on and actually let's
just just to kind of give ourselves some
closure here let's write it in sigma
notation so we could write the natural
log of 1 plus x to the third 1 plus x to
the third over our restricted domain
where the absolute value of x is less
than 1
is equal to
is equal to the sum
the sum
from let's say
let's say n
equals 1 to infinity
of x to the third
x to the third to the nth power so to
the first power the second power third
power
over n
this is x to the third over 1 x to the x
to the third squared over two oh and i
of course have to throw in let's see
this first one is
we're gonna have to care about the sign
so let me throw in a negative one
let's see negative one to the first
power should be negative but here it's
positive so i'll say negative one
to the n plus one
negative one to the n plus one power
does that work i think it does when n is
equal to one this thing just becomes
one this is x to the third over one when
n is equal to two
this becomes negative which it needs to
be and then this becomes x to the sixth
and we're over two and so there you go
we are done i found that pretty
satisfying